Now let's go on to drone shot crews,
soul and Emile
and
interact with me today. I need your
help. I came back from Helsinki,
Finland yesterday.
I was 16 hours on the road.
I then too bad 1:00 AM so
I need your help. You know,
I want you to interact with
me and Emily is a good,
a good opportunity to interact and get
excited because it's a very important
tax.
As I pointed out,
there is no education or theory
base out the Russo's mal and uh,
everybody who does education has
studied Amiel from cover to cover.
Most of them will disagree
with most of his ideas,
but you'll be provoked
by his ideas. Um, uh,
he is intentionally provocative,
says date switch.
Do upset you but makes you think
and don't dismiss it too easy.
Now,
before I go into a meal,
that is one more issue I would
like to come back about. Uh,
uh, um, Russo, social contract.
I made this point briefly in last lecture,
but let,
let me make it sharper because in the
questions I am asking questions about the
General Ville and I feel I
may not have eva give, uh,
give even enough meat to you, um, uh,
about the notion of the General Vale
now before I go.
So I have to come back because
there is one more um, uh,
Chore Household Chore.
Um,
one of the teaching fellows that reminded
me that the smiths lecture of come at
the day.
Then the test is you.
So what to do with this?
Uh, but I suggest, uh,
uh,
I will do a preview of Snitch,
a jurist day this week and I will put
my powerpoints before the lecture,
um, on the Internet so you can
read the powerpoints. Okay.
That feel yet you up in speed.
I hope you still,
they'll come to the lecture though.
Those of you who are also in varieties
of capitalism course can skip because out
of the 50 lectures I'm
giving this semester,
this is the only bond which overlaps.
It is the same lecture,
but I was given in the
varieties of capitalism course.
I hope you won't ask for a discount,
right.
That the professor did sell
the same product twice. Right.
Uh,
uh,
but anyway,
so those who did that lecture that they
feel very comfortable with Swiss can
miss the lecture, but I hope
everybody else, we will come Tuesday.
Alright, now, uh, Emile
and this is something, uh,
uh, no, no. Does the gender
reveal the gender reveal?
I didn't finish this file so that
it is right. An interesting, uh,
um, corn, Shasta
development in little show,
in the theory of social contract,
uh,
because it was so especially emphasizes
right that the social contract has to be
arrived at, uh, uh, by uh, um,
a universal consent.
Uh,
so he does emphasize that in
that I've into a social contract.
Um, we actually, uh,
have to exercise some popular
Suva identity and this is
an idea which is only an
element in lock, right? In some ways,
Russo moves a big step forward,
contract theory and theory
towards democratic theory,
popular silver ethnicity.
And in fact,
universal suffrage I mentioned he
did not advocate suffrage for women,
but advocated otherwise
universal suffrage. Uh,
what block was not willing to do.
But there is an interesting other
idea in Rousseau, which is, uh,
has,
uh,
important Kennel of tools and a very
disturbing the audio at the same time.
And this is the idea of the genital Ville.
I talked about this as a good example
of metal dialogical collectivism,
right? That Rousseau unlike, um, uh,
uh,
Hobbes or Locke or vive you'll see later
on meal or Adam Smith does not believe
that studying the individual actions,
we can understand what is society and
what the need of the society ears that is
a general veal over society,
which is more than simply
adding up all individual bills.
Um,
and these idea carried on in social
theory among those whom reveal,
discuss,
particularly by Emil Durkheim.
And that is clearly an
element of truth to it, right?
That there is some
universal good, right? Uh,
what is more than just a sum
total of individual interest?
Um, uh, when we are, uh,
you know, talking about how
scared that form, right?
And the needs of government's right
to provide health care for everybody.
Right?
Uh,
then the actually do believe that
it should not be left to individual
responsibility whether they
have house get insurance.
That would have to be, some people in this
room probably believed that. Right? Uh,
then you believe that that
is a General Ville, right?
That you have to overrule rather
individual, uh, to, uh, uh,
to, uh, make a decision. And you know,
that is the genital veal everywhere.
When you go to the college, you have
to get certain shots. So that was,
you are not allowed into
the college, right? It,
it is not living up to you to
decide, right. Whether you are,
had certain shots, they cannot, you have
to demonstrate to be in residence, right?
That is a general veal.
It's not assume that every individual is
a rational actor and people will not be
foolish.
Right?
And be irresponsible and not to
be up properly protected. You see,
this is a strong case that the
idea of genital veal makes sense.
That is some collective good.
Uh,
but we can understand that individual's
occasionally has to be forced to go by
these general bill right by the public.
Good.
But there is a big carb.
Love it.
The general via namely if that is a
general veal as such their own earth,
will it come from a how they will
know what the general deal is.
And Russo is an explicit about this rat.
He confronts it.
That's why he talks about the law
giver. He said, smart people like me,
we know what is good for society and
therefore we should figure it out.
But the genital Ville is and then the
popularly elected parliament will pass.
It is a law, but we are
the law givers. Right?
Well this is a very disturbing idea,
right?
And and disturbing idea,
which opens a Russo up to a totalitarian
interpretation that he argues that the
government knows better.
And in fact he argues that not the
government but the device philosophers,
v the intellectuals,
we know better but people into the star.
You think this is your interest? No,
I tell you, this is not your interest.
I know. What is your interest? There are,
this is a very disturbing idea how
owners do I know what is annual interest.
Uh, and of course, uh,
Russo's notion of general veal appealed
a great deal to Karl Marx and Raji
middle each learning and Moussa tone.
They love the idea that it is the central
committee of the Communist Party who
knows better than ordinary Chinese
or Russia what their needs are.
There must be a central planner
rather than individual actor,
which tells people what their needs are.
So the problem of genital Ville
is highly problematic, right?
You can hit,
you can make a case for it that
you need an assumption like that.
As I pointed out, that our
people in this room, right,
who believe that that is general
villa and the common good, right?
Other people here,
anybody believes ah,
that's okay. Yeah. Yeah. There
are people in this room of course,
uh, uh, and that other others
who would not be Dave, that,
I mean,
if you add an econ major,
I think you got enough in economics
to say no, no, no, no. Never, ever.
Uh, um, okay.
Now let's go to Mel because it's
actually has something to do it,
a different formulation
with the same idea.
So what is the story about Mel?
It's uh,
of course he himself is shock.
Um, and uh, he doused
us that he is a cheater,
a Alpha boy,
Mel,
and educate him from the early age is on
theall reaches adult hood and finds his
wife Sophie.
I told you of course that this is a very
idealized Rousseau because he put all
of his children in to orphanage,
employ a very lousy orphanage and
probably most of them or all of them very
early died in this orphanage.
But you know, uh, he's still
has ideas what he should have done if he
would not have been a bastard and will
not have that band on his children.
So what is the table of contents first?
He says,
well,
we have two rare,
a civilize savage,
a child born in the state of
nature in infancy and Chai.
Two and three of the lessons is a
gradual transformation from the state of
nature into society. Uh, then, um,
he, uh, Ben, uh,
adolescence comes then we have a fully
form App Tomeki individual by now and we
have to bring that person into society.
Okay.
And then,
uh,
he has these very complicated idea
that this transition from the anatomic
individual and state of nature to severe
society is that transition from our
more the salon to are more pro per a val.
This is a very complex concept.
Russo could have been more lucid
about what the difference is.
Then he laws, uh, uh, also, uh,
from English.
You think you understand it more easily
than you actually do because proper in
a,
in a franchise does not mean proper.
Proper also means myself.
Proper only means myself in
consideration with others.
Soya beans myself, besides
consideration of others, right?
So be careful, right? Uh, um,
were proper is not proper love,
right?
It is a self lava,
but of a self love in which
I do take into consideration.
I have had not only Egl
to put it with, uh, uh,
Sigma Fried
well,
and it has to happen otherwise
we will not have citizens.
He links this idea of AML proper ivy.
We'll have to talk about this
more in order to have citizens.
And he makes a crucial distinction
between the citizens and the bourgeois.
This is again, uh, the two
faces of who saw, right?
One phase of loose. So is, uh, uh,
a radical Democrat, uh,
deeply democratic individual.
And the other faces, uh, uh,
left radical and he's the first
really as far as I can tell,
but I reasonably know, uh,
the literature of the slams,
the first who is using the term bourgeois
in a pejorative way and makes this
crucial distinction between
citizen and Bourgeois.
Uh,
and [inaudible] are the
selfish businessman, right?
Who wants to have money and do not have
a commitment to the collectivity who do
not obey the genital Ville,
but pool,
so selfish,
narrow economic interest.
That's bourgeois in some ways.
He gives the tool to Karl Marx,
right,
to develop his theory, as we
will see later on. And March,
of course, loved Rousseau. Not only Marx,
Durkheim love to sue as well.
I mean that are many people who
love this character, the, his,
um,
uh,
shortcomings of his character. Well, uh,
what our domain teams,
uh,
the first important tms nature is good
society Vichie score rops very important
proposition. Um, very
powerful proposition.
This is something what the
marks also takes from Rousseau.
And this is what Durkheim also takes from,
from those short,
uh,
fear of death is not natural.
He continues, uh, if the,
it is forced on us,
forced on us by please,
philosophers and doctors.
And the first task is Magothy education.
Bell Ivy will elaborate on this.
I'll just foreshadow these block of ideas.
The second one is,
now the task is to turn the
savages, mobiles, savages.
That's a noble savage, right? The value,
we'll show you an idea into social beings
and from Amada swap to I'm were proper
bell thought makes our social,
it's a lovely idea. Provocative, ironic.
And I just love it.
What makes us social is pity.
All right.
And Ivo labored on this.
It's really so, so wonderful.
MMM.
And the big question is,
can the be citizens out being bourgeois?
What is the distinction? And then, uh,
he said,
what is civilization?
Civilization becomes coacher them
sexy sublimated into imagination.
It's very important. Yeah.
I feel labor on it then. I,
I hope you will be able to
relate to it as much as I am. Um,
uh, the right, uh,
he said that are really two
processes which makes us so shot,
pity and love,
but not sex.
It is Aerotek love, which is in
your mind as much as, as, as,
as,
as a newer sexual drives.
And then he suggest love
develops in three stages.
Uh, and I think that this
is absolutely wonderful. Uh,
uh, again, and I didn't
know, I certainly, I,
I can relate to this
rally, val. Right? Um,
the first stage is that you, you aren't
in love, but you don't know yet it home.
Uh,
you write an ad d for love and you
are looking for somebody to be loved,
but you don't really know yet.
You did not identify it.
But that is a sense, right?
That's your art in law. Well,
uh,
it happens certainly for the first time
in adolescence when they are 13 or 14,
and we suddenly realize that
there is a romantic stuff,
but we don't have the object of
our romantic feelings, right?
We have to find this out, but it
happens actually overs them. Uh,
one force in lover. Can I
tell you as an, as an old man,
it will happen later to life as well
that are rarely one love in life.
Right? Okay. Then, uh, he says,
um,
a lot of brings different people
together on the basis of differences.
Uh, this is very much a dear
Connie and idea, right? Uh,
for what binds people together can be,
there are differences and it makes
it very provocative argument.
Uh, men and women are
different. It's mostly,
he's mostly Rad as a
mere shoving his bastard.
But, uh, it's more complicated than
this. And I can your show you text,
but we will make you think,
ah,
this out completely dismissing him
just on some very damaging quotations.
What I also will show you,
all right,
so nature good society corrupts,
uh,
well. People in nature are good. Uh,
society corrupts well, this
is the opposite. Are you man,
uh, uh, to, um, uh, hops
or in fact, you know,
Durkheim's, uh, idea
that you need, um, uh,
uh,
more control over our
society is also post to,
um, uh, uh,
Russo's fund on an idea.
And he said, well, in a child does
not know vice and doesn't know error.
Um,
it is introduced to the child by society.
And then he got though he was
not much of a believer. Uh,
he, uh, gives a bit of
theological argument.
Everything is good as it leaves the
hands of the author of things God and
everything degenerates,
um, in the hands of man,
um,
mandarins everything upside down,
right?
He wants nothing as nature made art,
we are being cool to get rid of our
national national now national natural
instincts. Um, uh, and
this is again, lovely,
right?
Men must be trained like a school horse.
So it's a lovely also,
I think you sense,
right?
[inaudible] is very important distinction
between training and education.
Right?
Um,
once I had a conversation with Danielle
Bell have famous social scientists and
he said, we were talking about graduate
students and he said, you know,
my colleagues said, all of us talking
about training graduate students, he said,
what an outrage. You educate
students, you don't change them,
you train a dog. Now that's
through source point, right?
Training Sydney to giving skills and
telling them how to do things right.
A is changing.
Uh,
the point is education and I hope,
you know,
we tried to do in discourse
a bit of education.
That's why I don't emphasize that
you have to go back and memorize,
you know,
the citations from the orders come in
and in the blue book quickly copy in,
but you memorize and bill immediately
forget right after the test,
what often are expected
to do that is training.
Education is the process in which
we force you to think on your own,
right? That is education.
And he said, well,
the problem is that that is
too much chaining. Right?
Uh, like, you know, cutting back
to cheese, French garden, you know,
they caught back everything.
What grows right. Uh, to fit,
you know, the, what they
flew, mutual beautiful image.
It is or there's not unnatural. And I
also like this a great deal then you have,
you will not agree with this is a theater
of death is not natural in nature of
unaccept sits right.
Russo agrees with hops.
Yeah, indeed. Driven by the fear
of this. But this is not natural.
He claims that animal accepts deaths
right now by that it is true or not.
That's another question. I mean you're,
you may have seen, uh, you were a dog die.
You go and you have seen fair
in the eyes of a dog. So I,
I'm not so sure how correct
Russo's observation is,
but there is an element of
true story, right? That uh, uh,
Bob follows when they know
it is time to die. You know,
they go on their own and they lay down
and wait for death in a peaceful way.
That's what he suggested. He
said, what is put into us?
I think it's a wonderful deep idea.
The fear of theirs by philosophers,
doctors and great idea, right?
It's an a very important idea that we
are ruled by people who will not Polis
different type of knowledge.
And the essence, the,
the power of knowledge is that
it put fair of Daesh into us.
The doctors who will say, well,
ideal cure you, right? Uh,
the right and the police who will say
you will burn in Hell and therefore you
will, uh, fear of this.
Uh,
he said, you know, naturally, uh,
he would know how to
suffer and how to die,
but we are being sort of indoctrinated
to fear this and have anxieties in my
life. Now, uh,
this is why we need
the negative education.
This is a very provocative idea.
Became extremely popular
in the 1960s and seventies.
Those of you who do education probably
know Yvonne earlier trick, right?
Is pushing it to, uh, to the,
as far as you can, right?
But in the kind of counter
cultural educational theories,
it was very important that what
you need is negative education.
You have to get out of doors.
Silly ideas from people's
mind was so sad put in there.
Uh, and he said, this is
again, a lovely citation,
how didactic and pedantic craze
is all of us to teach children,
but they would learn much
better by themselves and to
forget what via long could
teach them. All right.
Uh, so this is again,
education is giving an opportunity for
people to use their mind rather than
indoctrinating them.
Uh,
uh,
and therefore he said the first act of
education should be purely negative,
right?
It goes,
it's not at all in teaching
virtue and a true sales,
but in securing the health from
vice and the mind from error,
that important.
That's right.
Uh,
the task of education, not training is
not good. Tell you what the truth says.
Right?
The task of education is to help your
brain operate sufficiently to tell what is
an ever right and to figure it out.
Then you are making gun at her.
Uh,
that's why that is no easy solutions.
That is no right answer to the question.
There are competing answers to
every important question, right?
And the task of education is to consider
the pros and cons to consider what
speaks for and against the evidence.
And then to make a judgment,
what is the proposition?
Uv like set, right?
To try to eliminate error.
That's what education is all about.
Okay.
Now,
and I'll do an issue is about
commands. And he said, and again,
I love it.
There shall be no commands.
The words or bay and command,
there'd be proscribed from the lexicon
and even more so duty and obligation that
he provocative. But again, I think
very deep thinking about it very hard,
right?
He said,
what we really should be in the process
of education do is to emphasize your
strengths, right? The emphasize necessity.
We emphasize in we without we,
we tried to figure it out.
What is outside of our reach,
what we cannot do,
we emphasize constraints, realistic
constraints upon our action, right?
Um, uh, that is the idea
of what should happen in,
in education. So, uh, the argument,
this is your duty to do that
is the wrong way to approach,
right?
It's not what the educators
should do to appeal to people's,
uh, um, uh,
guilt feelings to create deals in them.
Maybe I'll talk about this
more in Nicha right there.
The guilt feelings.
It's coming from a no,
don't create guilt.
Uh,
but on the other hand,
there are people what is necessary?
What are the limitations of your action?
Emphasize what you are capable of doing
and cottage them to get the best out of
them.
But all of us warn them that I don't
see that you can really go that far.
Don't push yourself too much because
you won't be able to make it.
That's what he believes education is.
Now this is a turning savage.
It's into social being.
Moving from our more this
swap to are more proper.
The labile. Seth, I'm more,
dishwasher is all of us good.
That is nothing wrong about it.
What Adam Smith's view call right,
south internist.
Um, now, uh,
the child is bored with [inaudible].
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
it's mine, right? Chad?
We say this is mine, right?
This is on ward the swap.
I want it right.
I'm more just swap as you will know from
uh,
um,
fried. I Vonda abreast
of my mother. Right?
I want to monopolize. This is
mine, right? That's amore the swap.
Well, both on the other hand, uh,
we have to extend our relationships,
we have to interact with other people.
Um,
and I'm more, uh, the proper,
the then v realize that is another people
who are also led by our more dis swat
and the figure it out, the
way how to live with them, uh,
by interacting with them. Now
that are, how does it, well,
does sociality them come from our
more proper valve? Does it come from?
And there are the first maximum is
it is not the human heart to put ourself
in the place of people who are happier
than the,
but only of those who are more pitiable.
It's so ironic,
but as far as I can to a whole neuron,
this is a home run,
right?
Think just Betty honestly about yourself.
All right,
man.
You know,
somebody was more successful
that which you can't.
Very hard to love that person.
All right?
If somebody is less successful than you,
you feel pity for them.
Suddenly your hearth farms op
Sadhana in youth theater responsible,
right?
Suddenly you want to call.
All right.
Uh,
the second maxim,
one bit is the others,
only those eels,
Ron,
which one does not feel oneself exams.
So we don't necessarily led
by [inaudible] van VC misery.
What is sort of outside of
our possible experiences. We,
we have love for pitiable people than
we think we can actually end up in the
same situation. That's where
the will have a more approach.
And the third maxim is
now
the pity one has four,
another misfortune is measured not
by the quantity of that misfortune,
but the sentiment,
one attribute should Dortch who suffer it.
Right.
Um,
so I think that's wonderful idea.
And now about compassion and pity.
One more time.
You said the airborne twice once to exists
and second time to live for Spanish.
If species reproduction and the young
adults become sensitive before knowing
what he's sensing,
uh,
is now a man truly born to live fan
it beginning to experience the others.
MMM,
soil.
It is actually our weakness.
What makes us social not that stinks.
It is our common miseries, which
turns sour horse. You feel managed,
I think really ironic but very deep ideas.
You can disagree with it,
but you have to think about it.
This,
that is clearly an element
of tools in the argument.
Okay.
Uh, okay. Uh, and I also
love the last sentence here.
He said,
PT is CV.
This is one of my favorite of
sentences or so. All right.
If he's so sweet to feel
pity for somebody. Oh,
I am so sorry for you.
Right.
Then you were heart this
overflow, right? Yes.
All right.
Uh,
no. And then the citizen and
the bourgeois, this is again,
fantastic
[inaudible] dot Astros.
Ron's fourth council of 300 ads.
Here's the fitted not elected in
the 300 representatives in Sparta.
He goes home, then lies tid, uh,
that were 300 men,
verse Yoda,
then he to be founded Sparta.
This is the citizen are U s citizen.
Uh,
when you only got a B minus and there
are 30 people in class who got an a,
do you feel how fortunate I am?
The time is such a great class.
The 30 people are better than I am.
Right?
If you'll figure it out today,
you are a citizen, right?
Then you'd have a lot onward
roper, right? That is his point.
And then another
woman had five songs in the army
and was VT news of the battle.
The hallut arrives scrambling.
She asks him for news.
You were five songs very killed,
and now she answers this slave.
Did I ask you that?
The volume,
the victory the manager runs through the
temple and gifts thanks to the guards.
This is the female citizen
I children died,
but the warm the genital Ville.
Well,
uh,
he who in a CVO order wants to preserve
the primacy of the sentiments of nature,
does not know what he wants.
All of us in contradiction with himself.
If you will never be
either a man or citizen,
he view would be a bourgeois.
He, there'll be knotting.
That's what Karl Marx loved,
right?
People who just pursue their
own self interest is not much.
No men be men.
Sexuality and love.
Now symbolization becomes sculptured when
sexy sublimated bodily desires turned
into imagination,
they will see that is greatly
inspires Zigman fried.
There are two mechanisms which constitute
social compassion, pity, and love.
And he also adds a,
a very provocative idea.
His time in the kind of
foreshadows postmodern.
So enlightenment,
the Metal Giles is the hoods
deprived from its meaning.
It's a cool, the rational world
of the marketplace, right?
And competitive,
isolated individuals.
That's what modern word,
enlightenment,
produced and delivered
became unerotic and poetic.
This is something which
will be a big row in Mexico.
Weber's idea of this enchantment.
Uh, or if you know mark,
who's a wonderful book Arrow
since civilization come
straight out of Rousseau,
Rousseau wants to bring back the Aerotek,
not sacks,
the Aerotek experience bell.
The lab develops since three stages.
As I said,
crest versus a dressed.
You are in love,
but you don't know yet to be at home.
Again. Think back, you were 13 or 14.
Uh,
you begin to search for somebody to love.
Then comes the discovery.
You found it. That's it.
That's the person I am love with Emil.
Find Stuffy,
but brings them together. He
said, is the differences right?
That they compliment each
other? Uh, Durkheim be lag you.
It can be similarity. What
brings us together. Uh, it's
a more complex argument,
but the origin of the idea is in rows.
So then the company's Dean bought
them by once you fall in love,
dawn thrush, right? As I said,
not sex ed course is
what is really the leaf,
right? I don't trust you. Two
beds go to channel. All right?
And then when you travel,
you think about the person you love,
you idealize that person and your mind
and that's when you is this love becomes
an erotic experience.
Then you can go home and you
can consume the love, right?
I think this is reality.
A wonderful
well and here comes a problem.
Ah,
his views on gender relations.
Oh,
bell men and women a difference.
And that means that they
ought to be told differently.
Uh,
uh,
if you would decide,
he said to raise a VM and
Maya mop the amount of like,
man, he said, man, the mill
me gladly consent to this.
Uh,
the more women want to resemble men.
The Last v man deal,
govern damn.
Well you can say separate
the sexy stops vision.
Uh,
but probably idea you heard before.
All right. Uh, um,
who wears the hat in the family?
This is the kind of argument right now.
The men are the bosses after at all,
uh,
Dell. Therefore, what
the education should do,
cultivate mass qualities.
Yeah.
Uh,
uh,
knock knock to cultivate man's qualities
in them, man. Right? Uh, but, uh,
uh,
raise it differently now
and here are the citations,
which shows you Russo the sexist,
uh,
hard to say. He's not the
sexiest pastor. The man is me.
It's specialty to please man. Ah, Val,
I'm sure at least half of the man in
this room are also outraged and I think
probably often outraged.
Uh,
but I hope that other man in this,
you'll not only me who is
upset by this statement. Well,
he said the men and men
are made for one another,
but that mutual dependence is not equal.
Men depend on the woman because of
the desire the man depend on man,
because both of their
desires and their need
people survive more. It if you saw
them than they would be south house.
I mean man, I mean this is of
course straight silly, right?
Uh, I mean, I was veto for the vibe. Know
how much more difficult it is for men
to survive this other woman then for a
woman to survive this out there,
man.
Now and then he goes on almost all
littler girls learn to read and write a
veteran Bulger nuns.
But as far as holding needle that they,
all those learn and gladly sewing,
embroidery and lace
making come by themselves.
So I mean nothing more should be said,
but there are other citations this wrong
and there are some boasts feminists,
feminists who actually liked this,
who,
so who says men and women
should be different.
Uh, he said, Sophie off to
be a woman as Emil is a man.
And then he goes for it.
He said in everything not connected with
sex woman is a man in some ways he's
formulating the idea of the gender,
gender equality, sexual differences.
Right. That's what he said.
The problem is if women
tried to look sex wise, like
Dave Man, right? Um,
that's I think an interesting
guy. And then he said, everything,
men and women having common
belongs to the species,
the human species and everything,
which distinguishes them belong
simply to sexual differences.
Uh,
and then he said in the Union of Saxes,
each contributes equally
to the common name,
but not in the same way.
Well,
uh,
Ivo suspect that most of
you if see him as a sexist,
um,
what some of you may actually see,
uh, the points, what he's making
a in these last sets of quotation.
Thank you.